I have to say when I delivered the
speech in Nassau Bon September 17 a lot
of comments whereabouts
okay European sovereignty this is a
French idea this is just a speech it
will never happen
but I've decided to make this world
Central to my political projects and
I've never forgotten that the very
concept of sovereignty as as well its
roots in the Netherlands
and this is a very European concept
350 years ago right here in the city of
The Hague
one of the founders of political
modernity Baruch Spinoza wrote in an
article 17 chapter 2 of instructatos
politicus I caught him
the right is defined by the power of the
multitude we call it sovereignty
I will not lecture you and Spinoza I
want to reassure you
I just want to highlight that in Spanish
philosophy
sovereignty is a means to guarantee the
sense of being to persevere in oneself
to put it plainly whoever wants to be
themselves must be Sovereign in other
words
and they want to insist on that
identity and sovereignty are intertwined
and I think this is very important to
understand this link and
the fact that
Spinoza makes it as one of the founding
concepts of precisely political
philosophy
because if you accept to lose your
sovereignty
it means if you accept to depend on
other powers
you put yourself in a situation not to
decide for yourself and not to be in
charge of precisely continuing
preserving developing your own identity
made during the pandemic
we discovered that we were dependent on
a lot of devices and a lot of drugs and
a lot of products suddenly and even
those who were supposed to cooperate
with us summarize decided to ban the
exploding months as long as they were
not served and protected
and during the war
those who decided
to cooperate to make trade with
neighbors even if they were not allies
Russia for energy
because we decided de facto
that trade could be the best way to
cooperate could create irreversible
links and precisely avoid the authors to
be aggressive
they decided to weaponize the energy
putting us in a completely crazy and
unbelievable situation
War just pushed us in a situation to
discover that
we have to reduce our dependencies if
you want to preserve the European
identity otherwise we will progressively
be dependent on everything and it's
probably due to the fact this is a sort
of convergence with what I heard Europe
was an especially European Union was too
much driven
by a customer approach
and not sufficiently by the citizen and
the producer approach
and we didn't build sufficiently how to
ensure our I would say Economic Security
and my intention and what I want to
Advocate is not to in a certain way
revert to protectionism and so on it
doesn't make sense
but to try to design with you and to
Define in a few minutes
what could be this comprehensive
Economic Security Doctrine
for the European Union to guide our
European action globally
and I mean to protect ourselves our
identity
and to put ourselves in a situation to
Define
our current and our future model for
ourselves